we're going to continue our conversation
though now about critical race theory
because it is that important and it
looks like it could now be infiltrating
the united states military you only have
to listen to the words of the joint
chiefs chairman mark milley describe
quote white rage as the reason for
january 6th protests
i want to understand white rage and i'm
white and i want to understand it
so what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault
this building and try to overturn the
constitution of the united states of
america what caused that
i want to find that out so now the
military is studying critical race
theory and millie wholeheartedly defends
it
but should we be even surprised since
biden took office the cia
even nasa have gone woke but don't worry
milli assures us that the latest
wokeness is only about
understanding the country we are here to
defend
i've read miles seitan i've read i've
read karl marx
i've read lenin that doesn't make me a
communist so what is wrong
with understanding having some
situational understanding about the
country for which we are here to defend
joining me now is senator tom cotton a
member of the armed services committee
senator always good to have you on the
program
is what's happening with the military
different and if it is
how so then what we're seeing happen
with school districts
in classrooms across this country
well well thanks for having me what we
see in classrooms and school districts
is very alarming because schools are
trying to indoctrinate young children
sometimes all the way down to
kindergarten
but america is a hateful fundamentally
flawed
irredeemable country and if we allow a
generation
of our kids to be indoctrinated with
those views then what does it matter if
we win
a few elections in the years ahead in
the military it is
at best a waste of time to have
students in professional military
schools or troops on the front line
going through training sessions
being exposed to critical race theory
concepts
but even further it helps undermine unit
cohesion
and morale you know when i was in the
army i can tell you we didn't look at
each other through the lens of race
or background or your last name or who
your parents were
we looked at each other as battle
buddies comrades in arms
who'd signed up to fight for our country
and were willing to die for the country
and for the man and woman to our right
and left and front and rear and what
really
caused me to dig deeper into this is
i've got a lot of friends who are still
in the service
and they started reaching out to me a
couple months ago with some of the
trainings
they were facing as a result of
secretary austin's so-called stand down
order
and since then congressman crenshaw and
i have been getting a lot of complaints
hundreds of complaints about these
training sessions that's one reason why
i pressed secretary austin on it
earlier this week i pressed the chief of
naval operations admiral gilday about it
as well
the army and our military as a whole
needs to focus on real wars
not on cultural wars you know senator i
like how you distinguish indoctrination
from education
milly suggests by the way that we're
only educating ourselves and our army
when we look into critical race theory
he says as you heard there
that i've read mao zedong and that
doesn't make me a communist i need to
understand the ideologies
that are presented to us some of whom
could be our enemy but the
problem is it seems like what's going on
with the military is less about
education and more about as you pointed
out
indoctrination i want you to take a look
at this ad from the united states army
it begins in california with a little
girl
raised by two moms
i also marched for equality i like to
think i've been defending freedom from
an early age
and after meeting with an army recruiter
i found it
a way to prove my inner strength and
maybe shatter some stereotypes
along the way that's the united states
army recruiting
ad right there senator so when i look at
that i worry what we're doing and i hope
i'm wrong
you served you also serve in the united
states senate i hope i'm wrong but what
i
see there from a distance was what
appears to be not education
but indoctrination
and that's what we've heard uh from the
front line troopers you know the young
privates the
uh sergeants who are the backbone of our
military officers who oftentimes are
involved in having to conduct these
training sessions
in some cases very much against their
wishes um
you know again there there's always a
place for instance
in college campuses to include our
service academies to say read karl marx
in a class on the history of western
thought when it comes down to training
sessions for our frontline troops
they need to be taught to respect
everyone irrespective of their race or
their sex or their ethnicity or their
religious creed or their political views
treat them with equal dignity and
respect period
and then they need to get back to
tactical excellence and operational
training
so we can perform the highest levels and
our troops can be ready to fight in
whatever kind of circumstances they
might face
all right senator tom cotton thank you
for joining us tonight here on the
program
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else